well the this has changed over time
at first when we began our work at the
Innocence Project and there's a problem
within the system generally there were
all kinds of what we call procedural
bars to getting a post-conviction DNA
testing able to offer the results in
court in fact there were no states that
permitted post-conviction DNA testing
and there were only nine states that
said that you could raise a claim of
newly discovered evidence to show that
you were innocent at any time so many
states had time limit statutes of
limitations in Virginia there was an
infamous 21 day rules twenty-one days
after the trial even if you found new
evidence of innocence he couldn't put it
into court as newly discovered in other
states it was one year or two years or
three years or six months I mean there
were all kinds of problems like this so
we were able to get past now in 48
states statutes that allow for
post-conviction DNA testing and
Massachusetts is one of the statute
states that doesn't have a statute but
you can based on what they call common
law you can usually get a test result
but they should pass the statute so the
point here is that there were from the
very beginning there were all kinds of
impediments to even getting this
evidence into court and at first when we
went into court and we said to
prosecutors oh look at this case there's
an obvious basis to do a DNA test and it
could prove somebody innocent and maybe
identify the real perpetrator why don't
you consent to it and in many instances
they would many instances they did not
not for particularly rational reasons I
must tell you which is really I guess
the subject of your question why would
anybody resist this right and then even
after the DNA proof came in why would
prosecutors still say oh no no no we're
going to appeal the conviction and that
is a question of for cognitive
psychology and
a lot of people thought about it I think
there's a number of factors the first is
very simple it's human nature people
don't like to admit they're wrong we're
all like that number two and maybe well
I don't know want to give primacy to any
of these they're all work together
there's the problem that when somebody's
convicted there's a victim or a victim's
family in the case of a homicide and the
prosecutor has said well this defendant
is a horrible person a beast and animal
in some instances they would say killed
this person committed this most heinous
of crimes and now you have to go back to
the victims family and say oh guess what
we were wrong well that's very difficult
for the victim or a family and we see it
so often in these sexual assault cases
in particular there was eye witness
misidentification so hard for somebody
that's been subject to such a brutal
crime to now who made an honest mistake
and making a misidentification and I say
oh my god I was wrong I mean you feel
doubly triply violated I mean it's a
horrible burden to carry so there's a
lot of reluctance to upset victims
within a community so that's a second
factor that inhibits prosecutors
sometimes and police from acknowledging
a wrongful conviction or even opposing
an effort to get a DNA test and then
finally and this may be more subtle but
I think it's a very very important
factor because in a lot of cases we
would find the prosecutor who was
standing in the way of the DNA testing
and refusing to acknowledge the obvious
implications of the new evidence wasn't
even in office when the crime was
committed and the reason I think that
some of these prosecutors were so
reluctant to go along with what was I
think clearly just outcome or even to
find out
the truth or get better scientific
evidence that would shed light on the
truth is that they're afraid of the next
case so if we have an exoneration and an
eyewitness identification case and now
I'm trying a new case in front of the
jury the jury had just heard about this
big exoneration and they're always big
news they should be too and they're
gonna be thinking ah well maybe I
shouldn't trust this eyewitness or maybe
that case involved police misconduct
maybe I shouldn't trust the police or it
was a false confession maybe I shouldn't
be so sure that a confession means that
somebody is really guilty and on it goes
so I think that they're worried about
the next case the truth is that if
you're a prosecutor that has a
reputation for going back and looking at
old cases and correcting errors I think
that your reputation for reliability
goes up